I have some new tour dates to tell you
about uh we've just added a third show
over there in Alan New Zealand on
February 24 we've also added a second
show in Brisbane in the Australia on
March 1 and second shows were also added
in Sydney Melbourne and Gold Coast um in
the Australia with limited tickets
remaining we also have limited tickets
remaining in Charlottesville State
College PA
Syracuse New York and Amhurst
Massachusetts all tickets are available
at theo. comom T Ur and if if you're
going to secondary sites and stuff and
they're real expensive just wait we'll
come back around and um and yeah I just
don't want you to wasting or just I
appreciate it but I don't want you
overspending thank you guys very much
for all your support love
you
we made
it uh Merry Christmas to you um happy
holidays to you if you don't celebrate
Christmas some people don't or they
celebrate it but they
don't care about Jesus or whatever or
you know they
don't you know I don't care if you may
some people celebrate Lloyd
Christmas and that's fine too um you
know it's whoever you're deity is people
have different deities and uh leaders
some people love
um you know uh Jesus some people love um
Buddha um what you know what I'm saying
there's different
uh deities that people believe in Papa
John some people two
mediums and a a two ler of sprite as
their lord and savior
people have different things that they
love happy holidays Merry Christmas
um yeah here we
are I can't believe we made it this far
man we're traveling into the future it's
the end of
2023 time
is keeps on ticking into the
future I'mma play a couple little
christas tun this is how I do it this
time of year some of yall know that
let's hear a couple of
[Music]
little yeah that's
very romantic kind of
or
soft very ICU Christmas
almost if somebody's in ICU you might
play this while you bottle feed
[Music]
them you're going to be
okay you're going to be okay Ronnie just
drink you some of this milk buddy drink
you some of this
milk yeah that has a very IC see you
Vibe I think you're going to be fine
Ronnie get you some of this milk Ronnie
get you a little sip of
it here's another one um that one was
called uh a Christmas miracle by one man
quartet over there and I don't know
where that's from or something sounds
like some prison [__] sounds like some
whites in prison did it or some sweds in
prison put that together beautiful track
there we got something right here from
from Paris for Christmas it's
[Music]
called lot of bag pipes up in that one
huh gets a little too Irish for it's a
little too bag a little too Irish for me
you know it's like uh I just just molest
me father and quit playing the tunes you
know I'll let you touch me if you quit
playing the bag pipe St Donnie I'll let
you touch my uh what do else we got here
that was by of North and here's
another
[Music]
one oh yeah
baby
mhm
M mhm
m y I like this baby damn come on I'll
lick my lips I'll lick your
lips my God baby that's what gets me
going
baby I want to
[Music]
just mhm I just want to take your
titties off your body and just put them
into my mouth baby girl love me
Lord that's a beautiful track right
there and that is by stir zetter
birge over there that's called Merry
Christmas Baby by stir stur sorry stur
zge out
there and here's another one we got
right
[Music]
here
oh yeah this is like you pushing a
senior citizen uphill in a wheelchair
kind
[Music]
of don't worry pop we'll get you there
don't worry
pop just keep your feet off the ground
pop we're going to keep pushing yeah
something very romantic about that one
right there that's called going home for
Christmas that's home for the
holidays over there we got this one
right here another
[Music]
one oh oh whoa oh that's said Urban
Christmas baby come on
now come on Santa
ooh ooh ooh Santa here
come on
[Music]
now
Santa Santa he out there Santa he in the
streets Santa he in the streets
Santa Santa he doing dry by gifting
Santa cooking chicken
Santa
Santa welcome to
Atlant
Atlanta
Santa and he got his all his L's over
there TI one of them you know that you
know that bro ti la booy he at the front
of the sleigh booy baby baby he look he
might not even take you booty take you
wherever the [__] he want to take
everybody bro you Santa be like damn
what the f what we doing down here we
down here in Baton Rouge we down here in
scotlandville baby what boot done took
us off track
Baby W
down oh that's Christmas baby well you
know I like to play a little bit of the
Christmas tunes in the beginning there
off of epidemic sound they just and I
don't work epidemic sound they just it's
a place you can go look and they have
different just pieces of music and
sounds and you can just go on through
them but that was magic Day by loving
caliber and I love that man I would love
to be able to have the experience of
having different
uh ethnicity Christmases you know get
you a little Chinese Christmas
baby get you a little you know pork
fried reindeer or whatever get get you a
little cut of that you know get you some
bok choy on some damn [__] grilled
Panda or whatever they they eat over
there Merry Christmas that's what I'm
trying to say
sorry stringing up these lights you I
don't know if you remember some of the
Christmas sound music they had over the
years that was the thing that got me
sometimes just the different sounds you
know and the first day of Christmas I
don't know if anybody remembers that
when uh
my true love gave to me five onion
[Applause]
r that [__] was I like that was fun like
I remember listening to that that was
always something fun to do with the
family you know on the birthday I C my
stringing up these
[Music]
lights Christmas BL
praise God baby Jesus is
born Jesus is
born Away in a
Manger no crib for a
bed dude that's a Christmas music can be
a trap it'll make you think you can sing
that's the only
problem it'll make you think you know
Last Christmas I gave you my heart
Christmas music will do it um Merry
Christmas to everybody thank you for uh
being a part of my universe sorry if I
seem a little bit uh all over the place
I'm off my got off my medication about
11 days
ago and um so I just you know I noticed
it even when I was talking with cat Von
D I was just uh I felt it was hard for
me to listen in a little bit I was just
I felt kind of um erratic you know or
not homo erratic just just all over the
place
yeah and uh I got a buddy that's homo
erratic that dude he's all over the
place bro and he's also hunting a little
bit of that dude meat you feel
me that freaking Christmas stick baby
you know what I'm saying boy he hunting
a little bit of that winter front Rudder
Bab you know I'm talking about that Wier
boy praise God shout out to everybody
that's gay and uh everything
gay Chinese baby lesbian everything baby
we love you guys
and and
uh black everybody European I'm just you
know we all are coexisting here in the
universe and um and I'm excited to see
us do that even better as time goes
forward
underneath the Chistmas
tree yeah that was Vince Vance and the
Valiants I like
them what else Silver Bells stringing up
these
lights sorry guys I'm all over the place
um I'm happy I'm happy that I'm that
we're hitting the end of the year uh
uh the only by the only guy that's got a
lot left to do this year usually is you
know who I'm talking about your boy
Santa Claus son everybody this year
getting uh OIC that's what Santa's just
Santa's been compromised bro I heard
it's just a dude just with a sleigh full
of OIC now that's what I heard it's just
some [__] white dude with a sigh full
of OIC bro and they got I heard they
paid up
you know a big Pharma paid the North
Pole enough they off work this
year so you just got you know is just
going to be a zic
dealer and people's on know zic that's
bro that's that fat crack that's what
people calling it that fat cane
baby people don't know zimp
it people Lo you'll meet a dude he lost
1100 lbs bro in 45 minutes
times have changed man it's a lean
Christmas man it's just going to be a
couple big farmer
reps uh just just humming uh injectables
out of a damn
Cessna all around the world
man yeah I and that just the I don't
know if uh zic seems safe man you'll see
somebody they're like yeah I'm 38 years
old old and uh I'm down to 55 lbs yeah
thank God I can fit into a lot of my
same clothes I wore in fourth grade yeah
my my skin makes a weird noise when I
smile but other than that man I'm
doing great they start [__]
glitching they just start you
know they're like I'm doing
great I I weigh seven pounds
uh I can't
remember who I
am my resting heart rate
is
two but I'm doing
well I'm doing
well um I'm doing
well I'm I'm on
O then they start burping you ever talk
to that OIC user you start talking them
and then
just did it start blowing bub it's like
some some dude you'll be talking to one
those impu they'll just [__] eat a
bug that flew by you're like what the
[__] and then just the side effects bro
some OIC or oans or whatever they call
them these [__] they got some side
effects bro they're like I can't close
my eyes or I
will [__]
myself they're like I can't breathe
anymore but I'm doing doing good I lost
lb I'm going to
heaven you're like what the [__] chill
out Melissa you need a [__] little
you need a smoothie Melissa you're
[__] losing your [__] people are
shooting up in their cars at
lunch and no shade there man I'm um I'm
just Clowning I'm not trying to hurt
nobody's feelings there but F Bells will
be
ringing I can't bend my knees
anymore every dream I have has Katie
Perry in it but I'm doing better than
ever can somebody close my eyes for me
so I can get some
rest I ain't losing my mind I try to to
jump out of window to take my own life
but I only
weigh 17
o so I
just floated back down to
earth than you
OIC has anyone seen my
children
but then you have the alternate guy you
have the guy like man [__] imp doesn't
even [__] work you know I T you know
I've been on the ship for two years I
gain 100 pounds
man I gain aund
100 100
Hot N nut pounds
man you know and then a guy blame his
wife my wife keeps [__] shooting the
[__] into me and I'm [__] you
know and then the guy will lick his lips
for like 70 minutes you know and then
pull a [__] beautiful little gum drop
out from under his tongue or something
or he'll keep a damn uh butt of scotch
up in his mouth and that he'd been
sucking on that [__] you know but yeah
I think Santa's just that's I don't know
if Santa's going to make it this year I
think he might have been taken over by
uh
by big farma I wouldn't be shocked but
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if Santa's
on the peptides everybody is we all do
things and try stuff
to want to be different feel different
um I'm just fascinated by the uh you
know I I I've known women who are
driving down to Mexico to get OIC or OIC
or what whatever they got down there you
know oh homie you're going to be [__]
skinny homie do if you go to prison you
can just SC Right Between the Bars homie
you're out of there dog they got nothing
on you dog yeah that people didn't
realize like OIC is just [__] you're
free
homie reol
Pap they busted a lady with 60 GRS of
fake OIC over there outside of a
Vineyard Vine
you know
[Music]
and all we can do is pray for but still
it's this is real
[__] it's interesting it's an interest
interesting uh phenomenon is what it is
that's a damn phenomenon you know uh and
people are using it and people
are some people are using it healthily
and some people are not it seems like
just like anything you know I had times
in in my life where I use steroids
healthily times where I use steroids
unhealthily you know dude I bought a
buddy of mine who drowned he drowned
because he well he he uh he was trying
to hide from the police
underwater and you can't you can do it
but you can only do it for about 40
seconds and he
drowned
um
and
uh but yeah I bought some [__] from him
once steroids or something I don't know
what it was gave me a full body
rash um it made it hurt when I would
blink my
eyes and if you've never had that
it's when you have cuz like every time
my eye my eyes would touch each other it
would
like because you don't realize how many
times you blink your eyes and you're
just
like so that [__] was horrible I had a
full body rash dude that was crazy my
arms they look like I like I had oven
mitts on my hands they were just but I
kept using the [__] I used all 11 weeks
of it
and uh yeah it was so we all try things
we all try stuff you know that was crazy
I can't believe I did that made me wet
the bed at night too and I was already
wet in the bed
so it's
just it was just a lot you know it just
real piss heavy time baby praise God
Merry Christmas guys if you're low on
time then you've got to make the hours
you've got a whole lot happier with dash
pass from door Dash that's right
everyone deserves to feel like a VIP
that's right and with dash pass from
door Dash you can you can
dash pass is the one membership you need
to get the most out of door Dash and
everyday life sign up for dash pass now
and you'll get your first month free
that's right dash pass members get $0
delivery fees and up to 10% off eligible
door Dash orders including groceries
drinks Personal Care items and more
that's 50% off up to a $10 value when
you spend $12 or more after sign up for
dash pass with code Theo 23 that's right
t h EO number two number three subject
to change terms apply sign up for more
become a dash pass member today you got
to stay hydrated during the holidays
that's key baby if you ain't hydrated
you ain't nothing you'll be looking for
your own nuts in the damn Forest that's
for sure what I'm talking about is a
liquid IV it's what I use for hydration
I get the packet it's a powder you put
it in the water you mix it that water
tastes M the best it's it just tastes
like hydration it really does that's
when I use it I use it after I go for a
run I use it when I get up in the
morning so I can really just feel just
just moistened
up that's right with three time the
electrolytes of leading sport drink no
artificial sweeteners and zero sugar
contains eight vitamins and nutrients
for everyday Wellness non GMO and free
from gluten Dairy and soy grab your
liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20% off when you go to
liquid
i.com and use code Theo at checkout
that's 20% off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code Theo at liquid
i.com anyway I love you I know I'm all
over the place
ah but it's just been a year man what a
year what a year and thank you for
listening to the to the podcast this
year and um I really can't thank you
guys enough I can't thank you enough for
just letting me be a part of your life
or even if you don't even listen [__]
even just keeping it in your thing and
or just let me bother you not me be a
part of your life dude like I'm some
kind of damn
uh you know like I'm just some kind of
um you know like I'm athletes foot or
something just uh just thanks thanks for
supporting me because you you've helped
this this whole uh we've gotten to do
interesting stuff and talk to some
unique folks and I think because people
have uh paid attention or tuned in or
spent time since we've spent time
together on here that we're going to get
to have other unique people in that's
kind of crazy cuz I don't dude if I were
me I wouldn't let these people talk to
me but they keep doing it
so um yeah I'm excited and it's just
been uh it's been a lot of fun and I
hope it's been fun for you too and uh
yeah and I just want you to know that I
think about that I think about making it
um making it interesting and and fun for
you guys guys and um and yeah I'm just
I'm just grateful man uh you know and I
feel a little bit happy about it too I
mean I feel happy but I just really in
my heart I feel I think just thankful
you know that's what I feel like
um yeah I'm trying to sorry I'm trying
to explain how I feel and feel at the
same time and for me that's always been
kind of a tough thing to do
you know it's tough sometimes to feel
and explain how you're feeling at the
same time um but yeah happy uh Holidays
and Merry Christmas to you guys and um
yeah I just can't believe what a year do
we got to talk to Hulk Hogan that was
crazy and um who else dude Dana White
that was bananas and
inspiring who El man stavos and
um uh John Veri just interesting people
you know everybody Drew just Caleb
Presley man who's
a well just a dear friend of mine some
of these people have
become just I don't know it's just all
been
crazy you know and
um yeah I I I got off my medicine man I
got off my medication I take I take
Lexapro and I uh I don't take a large
dose I think it was 20 and I got down to
10 and then I'm off and it's been
interesting because I've had a lot more
feelings man I've had a lot more
feelings and some of it I'm grateful for
because I I was just not having any
feelings you know I was just not having
any feelings everything was kind of fine
you know and and sais wasn't having any
feelings and so I was like I need some
feelings man
um you know I'm making sure that I have
like just have friends and stuff that
know that I'm off of it so uh if
anything seems too crazy
um so I'm just trying to let my feelings
just kind of settle or just get back to
like a
baseline so um I'm hopeful about that
and I've been making sure I do a lot of
running and stuff to just keep my energy
up so yeah I just want to kind of have
some freaking feeling feelings dude on
on on anti-depressants I don't have any
feelings people are like Hey how do you
feel and I'll just be like um yeah bro
you know I'm just not H I'm just not
having a lot of feelings I think on
anti-depressants so I want to have some
more feelings so then I can make some
more decisions based on how I
feel uh so that's an that I think that's
something that's really like a new
adventure
um yeah we've had a lot of beautiful
calls and uh we're going to get into
some of those
[Music]
um yeah what do we have
here this one says what's up with the 12
Days of Christmas right here let's
it hey Theo it's Johnny B John and
Christmas is coming up and you know that
song The 12 Days of
Christmas we dude's giving his his woman
a bunch of stuff and he that song he
gives his woman 17 Birds mhm
including six
geese and I don't I don't think I don't
think a woman wants 17 Birds bro it's a
euphemism dog it's a euphemism man
that's what I'm saying baby they want
that ba they want that body bird homie
that
wer
that ski Swan baby you know what I'm
talking about that [__] slurp warbler
dog that's what they want that red build
blast oral homie you feel me that SK
parakeet homie you know what I'm saying
suck me off suck me
off me
off Su me
[Music]
off shck me
sh shck
suck me
up suck me
up that's what they talking about baby
that bust Mard homie you feel me that's
what they you know so that's what you
got to understand it's a euphemism man
this a
euphemism they want that thing baby they
want that yuming bird
dog that nut neck body ostrich baby that
bust Mard homie that's what they want
that's what they
want so you got a plan ahead there all
right let's take another
call what up Theo this is
Hunter um I'm just calling I've got a
bit of a dilemma right now do tail
brother onward uh recently you know I
was making out with this girl mhm
and we was we was making out for
probably you know one one minute and I
just busted a nut right there oh yeah
and I don't know what to do so I was
just calling
to kind of get your guidance on that and
you know I'm just just don't really know
what to do oh yeah buddy well
look that's just some nut homie that's
all you know there's nothing you're not
a bad die you don't need to be scared or
nothing you're doing fine
um I think you might you know who know
if you if you were only making out you
might have a damn your pH balance might
be off or something you might have be
you know be like a plus six or something
you you know you might want to get your
damn levels checked or something or at
least have somebody do that on
you while you look at a nudie mag or
something you know
because you know you want to make sure
you're not
just vibrating so much if you get around
a you know a nipple that you're just
uh you're just sprouting and creaming
all the time for no reason you know
just sprouting and creaming you know for
just you know you don't want somebody to
flip on a light switch in a distance and
you [__]
just just [__] put own eye out with
that with that bust homie that [__]
bust but yeah you're doing fine buddy I
think yeah you your your levels might be
up or down or something you might not
have you might uh could have been
something you
ate you know if sometimes if I have some
um what are they call like zesty little
like uh
little um piece it's like a green bean
but it's [__] it's for violence you
know it's like um uh peppers like a uh
red peppers you know I'll shoot a robin
off a fence you know if I if I start
popping off after that but um you're
probably going to be fine buddy and it's
okay I think God just wants to warn you
says hey buddy you're going to be
really you know you're going to be on
the front lines for us because you like
to
shoot and just be
careful so and second of all I'm proud
of you man I'm proud of you for
ejaculating you know too many men feel
ashamed when they eat Jack or whatever
and you out here busting and creaming
and creaming and busting over there with
your lady and it's that time of year too
it's winter dude if you
can't if you ain't coming in the winter
buddy what are you
doing you know I don't think you know
that's a winter sport buddy so you out
there just uh uh just stirring your own
eggs buddy do your [__] Daddy get out
there and [__] get your [__] boy bust
out homie young
killer but uh yeah brother I love you
man and yeah you might just have that
that extra energy in you you you ever
see somebody that rub their feet on the
carpet and then they come up and [__]
zap you like that that might be you boy
you might just have you might just your
your pH balance might be a little H you
we want to get that [__] checked out
buddy or have somebody take your pulse
while you Jer off you know and see what
happens to you buddy you're doing good
though love you Daddy Merry
Christmas bells will be
ringing they say it's
Christmas this say it's
Christmas I love that I love that season
man
um what else else
uh let's take a call that happens right
here yo uh Mr
vaugh Man on your recent podcast you
were talking
about uh you
don't uh you're afraid to talk about
certain topics because you don't know
enough
man you you got to take that pressure
off of yourself man I don't know
nothing I mean I may even be cognitively
deficient I mean I don't even know you
ain't got to know nothing man you just
ask questions you just have people
on ask questions do your solo episodes
just ask questions man you ain't got to
know nothing you're just you're just
throwing stuff out there man you're
trying to figure it out like the rest of
us so don't worry about that man you
just keep doing your thing don't be
afraid you um you mean a lot to a lot of
people man you're making a big impact so
the more courageous you can be the more
people will follow that and that's what
we need
so thanks
man thanks dude uh you know
um you know I
think yeah I don't know what I'm
doing yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you man
yeah I don't know what I'm doing man I I
know I'm
trying but yeah I don't know what the
[__] I'm
doing yeah I'm just being I'm just just
being a human I'm just trying my [__]
best
man you know most of the time anyway I
don't know sometimes maybe I'm even
not but yeah I think I've just always
felt so much pressure man I've always
felt so much pressure to get it right
you better [__] get it right
you
know I've always felt like I wasn't
uh like I had to get it
right or there was no value to me or to
to whatever to whatever I was doing it's
like if it's not
perfect there was no
value
and so I think that's still how I
operate sometimes like I got to get
everything
perfectly yeah and it's just impossible
man and I'm tired of like H
yeah thank you man yeah I just I think I
did need to hear something like
that
um you better get it right that's what I
would always kind of feel like to myself
you better get this sh you better you
better get this
right that's the voice inside of
me it never had any patience it never
had any patience with me the voice
inside of me never had any patience with
me
um and then and then and you know what I
don't have a lot of patience with myself
either which is kind
of
which I deserve to have some more
patience with
myself yeah I deserve to have a little
more patience with
myself
um yeah so thank you man I think I
needed to hear that I do feel like I
can't do it all I do feel like I don't
know what I'm doing I do feel like I'm
trying my best I do feel like sometimes
I'm doing okay I do feel like sometimes
I'm not doing okay I feel like
uh yeah I feel like I'm also never going
to live up to the expectations that I've
set for myself because I set unrealistic
expectations yeah and I think I set
unrealistic expectations
because
um because if I never meet him then I'll
always be not good
enough yeah yeah thanks for
just making me think about questioning
myself too just asking
questions yeah there's nothing wrong
with if I don't know there's nothing
wrong with me if I'm not perfect there's
nothing wrong with me you know it's
okay
um yeah I've just always put so much
pressure on myself to be
perfect I've always put so much pressure
on myself to be
perfect man yeah [__] makes me angry
when I even think about
it like you better [__] be
perfect or you don't mean anything you
know that's it's some old story in my
head or something I'm not saying that
right now to myself I'm saying I'm
trying to just feel that story you
know you
better yeah like if I can be perfect
I'll show them that I mean
something yeah if I can just do things
perfectly they'll see that I have value
you know I
think and then you never can do things
perfectly it's impossible right and so
then you're just I'm always setting
myself up to not feel good enough
because I make my expectations of myself
unrealistic and so I can never achieve
them and so I'm always
just not enough for myself you know
um so thank you bro thank you for that
message I I
yeah yeah it's like man I got to get
this right or I'm wasting everybody's
time that's how I feel a lot of times
too
uh I think that's where I'm just trying
to say where some of that pressure feels
like to me it's
like you're wasting everybody's time
time yeah I wish you would yeah I think
it just that goes back to old stuff for
me or whatever you're wasting
everybody's time you better get this
right yeah look I yeah I uh I appreciate
you just yeah saying that man I think
sometimes I got to think about that
stuff and I I this year has been I think
one thing it's been tough I haven't had
enough time to [__] think or feel
[__] that I just haven't had enough time
to feel anything man everything's just
been so busy and I think the world's
just so busy
now you know I mean yesterday was one of
the first times I I went to a AA meeting
at the end I went to eat with the guys
at the meeting because I had some time I
was like I don't have anything to
do [__] I [__] enjoyed
that yeah son we're so damn busy we
don't even [__] know we don't I don't
even know
myself I'll get to the damn end of life
and I'll sit there and be like hey who
who were you buddy yeah
yeah what' you like to do I finally
start asking myself the question because
I just jumped on the on the on the train
I just jumped I just jumped on on the
zipline yeah but thank you man thank you
for helping me think yeah just ask my
self questions man I used to love doing
that and I
just yeah it it's just
important we got another call that came
in here let me see what we can do hey
Theo um I was just wondering what like
the thoughts in your head are like
because Like Mine mine's like you I
ain't even gonna lie like me and my best
friend and her dad were talking about it
and all of our thoughts sound like you
so I was just wondering what your
thoughts in your head sounded like all
right bye Jesus loves you oh thank you
there little lady little kitty cat uh
Jesus loves me thank you I hope he does
and I hope he don't love me too much
either you know some of
these they got these
uh you know these you don't some people
like G they don't know what jesuses do
when they just think he being kind of
zesty or whatever out there but I don't
know if I think that you know I just I
love him and yeah I hope he loves me I
hope he but yeah if he shows up and
he's if he's a little too zesty I just
wonder you know if he's like you know
the last supper was
[Music]
[__] you know I don't know I just
yeah I I love him I yeah just tell him I
love him and
um and yeah I don't know what the
thoughts in my head I don't know my
thoughts a lot of times I don't know
what they sound like some of them are
[__] pissed off and some of them
aren't even wearing anything I'll tell
you that and yeah some my thoughts they
just are like looking for me that's what
I feel like my thoughts are looking for
me and um I'm looking for them but we're
just we can't do it so but yeah I love
you thank you all right we got a call
here all right so I got a question my
name is Big Willie and uh I was what's
up Big Willie let's hear more wondering
I'm trying to save up for a new dirt box
but I don't know how to get some
money so I'm just calling for that now
you know you know what I'm saying get
any tips for me you know all right
see what you're trying to so thank you
Willie for the call um you're trying to
save up for a new dirt bike but you
don't know you don't have any money and
you're calling you're wondering how to
get some
money get a job I think get a job homie
that's what I would do I get a [__]
job Willie that's how they do it you get
a job they give you some money you get a
dirt bike you get into an accident on
your dirt bike and you are in intensive
care for a long time and
uh and that's how it works man that's
how life works so I think yeah you just
got to stay on the path and fill out an
application will it praise God baby good
luck BB what do you call a person who
speaks three
languages trilingual maybe someone who
speaks two that's bilingual someone who
speaks one American only 22% of
Americans speak a language other than
English at home start learning a new
language this fall and be the exception
not the rule because with Babel you
start speaking a new language in just 3
weeks that's right I've been using it to
learn more espanol instead of paying
hundreds of dollars uh for a private
tutor or fooling yourself with language
apps that are a little more than games
babbles quick 10-minute lessons are
designed by over 150 language experts to
help you start speaking a new language
in as little as three weeks Babel is
designed by real people for real
conversations all of Babel's tips and
tools for learning a new language are
approachable accessible rooted in real
life situations and delivered with
conversation-based teaching here's a
special limited time deal for our
listeners to get you started right now
get 55% off your Babel subscription but
only for our listeners at
babbel.com
[Music]
Theo get 55% off at babel.com
Theo spelled
babbel.com
EO rues rules and restrictions apply
bluechew that's it you want to feed
yourself something that's going to help
you get that Wier up that's it baby the
process is simple bluechew you sign up
at bluechew.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days that's right
the best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy Blue Cho tablets are made
in the USA and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discret package
bluechew wants to help you have better
sex discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and do it blue chew
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as Viagra
Calis and Levitra but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises bluechew
wants you to have better sex discover
your options at bluechew.com chew it and
do
it and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluechew free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
$5 shipping that's b c hw.com promo code
t h EO to receive your first month free
visit blue.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank blue for sponsoring the podcast
all right let's take one more call here
man
um hey what's up Theo my name is Trevor
I'm from Kentucky what's up Trevor baby
T rev baby that's how you break that
down onward uh man I just celebrated
nine months of sobriety from drugs and
alcohol man and my life's going great
you know let's go uh it really really is
man I fell in love with a girl oh come
on I don't know if she fell in love with
me or not yet but we're gonna see that's
that but I'm definitely in love with her
let's go and um I don't know man I just
wanted to I just wanted to say that man
yeah and uh I thankful for you and your
podcast man you bring a lot of light to
a lot of people's lives
man
gang baby that's it and Trevor got it
baby nine
months
tras baby that's 36 weeks daddy Trevor
got it baby nine months let's go t
rever and you got to say it baby yes say
it that's a part of this call I really
adapted with right
here uh but I'm definitely in love with
her and um I don't know man I just
wanted to I just wanted to say that man
and uh I'm thankful for you and your
podcast I just wanted to say that that's
the thing so yeah I don't say things I
don't you know I don't I
don't I don't even speak my own damn Joy
sometimes I don't even let myself hear
my own
Joy
yes say
that say that man you got nine months
you somebody you
like that's powerful daddy you hear
that you hear that man you hear
that man I'm just
uh let me think about any
other man today's episode has been just
all over the place guys I've had to
start and stops a bunch of times it's
just been a a tough time for me to get
like a good flow
going you know I just feel kind of r
battled and that's okay I feel you know
uh I don't know it's okay everything's
okay it's
okay you
know it's
okay
um it's been a fun year
and and I'm excited to see what next
year could be like
and and I hope that this holiday season
is something that you make nice for
yourself you know I I I always re
realize that um and I always forget too
that if I want the holidays or anything
really to to be special I have to I have
to be a part of making it mean
something you know uh I need to show up
I need to be activated and
um be a part of bringing the joy and not
just expecting to take take the Joy or
receive the Joy or I I need to show up
with some something it don't have to be
a something an item or something I mean
sometimes it can be but I need to if
something's going to mean something
then it'll mean even more if I show
up with the idea that I'm going to make
this mean something you
know and that could be if you're going
to take a ride with your child somewhere
and do something nice with them or go
shop you know or if you're going to
spend some time with your loved
one uh and y'all are going to go do
something
and you know to
just try and make a little extra effort
to make it mean
something you know a lot of times in my
life I've had opportunities uh to make
things mean something and I'll I'll I'll
choose
to kind of just be a kuding or be quiet
or try not to have fun sometimes I I get
afraid to have to be a little bit more
joyous you know
um you know so I think that's something
that I wish for this holiday
season
uh is that if you're like me sometimes
when there's a chance to
be to joke or to have sometimes I'll
just get a you know I'll I'll
I'll kind of shut down or I want to you
know if somebody else ask me to do
something I won't want to do you I only
want to kind of do my ideas you know
it's like so I just hope that this
holiday season I'm gonna try to be a
little bit more
like if somebody else you know I'm going
just try to go with the
flow
and and help the flow have a stronger
current you know with my own attitude
that's really what I mean I'm going to
try that you know because it helps me
too it helps me when I get outside of
myself a little bit you know and
um yeah so I'm going to try that a
little bit more this year that's
something that I'm going to look forward
to do
um
yeah so in instead of just continuing to
ramble I just
um yeah I want to try to show up a
little bit more this Christmas and be a
part of the joy a little bit more and
even if the game is on do things that
are engaging with people I care about
take a walk with somebody or [__]
tickle some little [__] I don't care do
something that is
uh you
know I just want to try to contribute a
little bit more this year if I can
that's one of my Christmas wishes for
myself
um
yeah and that's it
dude and that's really really it
[Music]
bro Silver
Bells Silver
Bell it's Christmas time in the
city
um yeah I don't know I got a bunch more
things on my mind but I think I just I I
I just am going to I don't know I don't
I think I just I think I'm just going to
just sign off for the year man you
know just sign off for the year we've
done it's been it's been quite a year
you know and just I'm glad we got to be
alive this year together and
um
yeah yeah I really am um
and that's all I got sorry to just keep
dragging that I kind of it's kind of
like the end of a date I feel like a
little bit you don't know where you want
it to you know like you're like just
standing in the yard kind of talking but
and nobody kind of knows what's going to
happen or whatever um so that's a little
bit how I feel but that's exciting
because that's a little bit of energy
that's like kind of fun you know and so
that's a good way to close things out
man um I want to let you know as always
the hotline is 98566
[Music]
um and yeah just thank you so much for
being a part of my life and and uh for
letting me be a part of your life um
thank you to our producers uh Zach and
Nick and Ben and Colin um for helping
get this show done every year um
every 52 times a a year week every week
and um yeah thank you
guys
and
uh yeah I guess that's kind of it I'm
just [__] rambling I don't know I had
an impossible biscuit or something like
seven hours ago and then I just been
having some uh Celsius
so I'm
basically I'm just like everybody else
so that's
it
uh Merry Christmas Happy New Year's to
you guys and um yeah thank you for being
a part of my life and letting me be a
part of yours and and uh and I love you
and I look forward to seeing you guys in
the New
Year I'm
upstairs be good to yourself baby
[Music]
gang
O Merry Christmas
baby raineer coming out to
play Santa Claus is packing the presence
making sure you've been behaving
okay
Merry Christmas
honey the
snow